are you with me all right let's go
leviticus 1 we'll read from verse 1.
third book of the bible if you can
condense leviticus to one word it would
be holiness
do you have that let me pray father
be with me i enter into this phase of
the message be with me dear god please
in jesus name amen
and the lord called unto moses and spake
unto him
out of the tabernacle of the
congregation saying speak unto
the children of israel and say unto them
if any man if you bring an offering to
the lord
he shall bring the offering of the
cattle even of the herd and of the flock
cattle being bulls the herd being
domestic animals flock being sheep all
right
if this offering be a burnt sacrifice of
the herd